welcome chassis all over the world good
morning good afternoon good evening
wherever you're coming to us from i'm so
glad you're here we're so excited to be
celebrating season five of chesapeake
shores welcome to a live virtual event
of course celebrating season five of
chesapeake shores hallmark channels hid
series premiering this sunday august
15th i'm deidre behar from entertainment
tonight it's truly an honor to be here
with all of you joined by some of our
favorite faces the o'brien's themselves
please help me welcome the cast of
chesapeake shores tree williams who you
know as mick
hi
barbara niven who plays megan
lacey j maylie who plays jess
brendan penny who's kevin
and andrew francis who plays
connor hi everybody
how's everyone doing it's been a roller
coaster of a year of course we're still
at home but i see you smiling and of
course i know you're excited about
season five at chesapeake shores how you
doing
great it's good to be home
yeah you like being at home
we miss the island it's it's hard
because you're there and and it's
and it's this beautiful peaceful place
and then we have all this family around
us but we miss our other family so it's
kind of a catch-22 but good to be home i
also miss an air-conditioned room that
was really nice
well look when the weekend
right andrew
yeah
i want to jump right in because it's
been a minute since the chessies have
been indulged with our favorite show
chesapeake shores and you know i know in
season five a huge theme is going to be
new beginnings so i kind of want to talk
about where your characters left off in
season four and kind of the trajectory
moving forward into season five so you
know treat and barbara i want to talk
really quickly um about where we left
things off as mick and megan's bromance
started bubbling up and where do you see
it going in season five
take it away tree how about it barbara
well i think it is fun to be rekindling
this thing
and
when you come back together after being
apart for a long time you bring some of
the old baggage but then if you're
i just think every time she looks at
mick
she remembers she gets the goosebumps
and the heart goes pewdiepie again and i
think fans are going to like
the relationship and as it develops
because
um
we're both afraid to really bring it up
because we don't want to mess what's
what's happening but man it's nice and
let me tell you how wonderful it is to
act opposite treat williams and
do those those scenes with him i mean
it's just such an honor to work with
this cast everybody brings such um
such a wealth and depth of character and
um and life experience to it and we we
have a blast together
and it's fun everybody is so funny
something that we don't really see on on
camera as much
um but everybody is is just got huge
personality like they crack we crack
each other up the whole time
i mean tree that's some high praise from
barbara niven how does that make you
feel
makes me feel good i'm glad she answered
because i don't remember where we left
see what i mean
i just saw the writing and i said oh
good we're getting along this is great
as we went forward but uh it's been a
really uh uh i've speaking for myself
i've had more fun this year than any of
the seasons writing is spectacular the
cast is in great spirits and i think we
all really knew we were doing something
special this year
yeah we have a new show runner this year
thief sutton who is multiple emmy
award-winning uh guy for um what was it
cheers and boston legal goals he brings
such um amazing writing and depth to us
it's intelligent it's funny and it's a a
real homage to like the old 30s movies
that's what treat always keeps saying
right tree yeah there's a character he
introduced
called mandrake he's right he's like a
butler out of a 30s comedy
out of uh one of those cary grant movies
but it's just really wonderful writing
and you know i think
not since it's been a long time since i
thought i can't wait to get up in the
morning and go to work and do this stuff
it's really we all look forward to it it
was so good yep
okay so barbara for fans who are really
rooting for this mick and megan
uh rekindling of the sorts what can you
tease for fans how romantic are things
gonna get in season five uh well in the
very first uh episode there's a little
smooch which was kind of fun and um
we can't really reveal too much but just
suffice it to say that um
megan watches mick go through a lot uh a
lot of uh consternation with his
business and
um there's still the
the push pull like how much do you
reveal about how you feel because
maybe you're going to get rejected again
but oh my god look at what what would
happen if maybe we just go all in so
there's a lot of exploration like that
like we do in real life and i think the
fans are going to be really excited
about where it goes but there's also
some cliffhangers at the end too so we
can't give away too much but it's going
to be epic pretty much
i like that word i like that word a lot
i can't wait to watch as hopefully the
romance continues to unfold uh i want to
pivot over to brendan hi brendan hello
how are you doing
because
you know
um i'm really excited to see what
happens next with kevin and sarah you
know they've opened up this conversation
about starting a family uh the the
challenges and the excitement and all of
that that comes with it what can you
tease about their family planning
journey in season five
yeah i think uh you know obviously
with someone as lovely and as beautiful
as sarah
is evan's definitely excited to start a
family
um
and uh no i just i think that um
you know i think that together they're
really ready to take that next step and
i think that he's definitely been ready
to kind of take on those challenges and
he obviously wants a very large family
coming from a very large family which is
uh
you know it's
maybe not met with such enthusiasm but
they kind of they they take it in stride
and they start to plan forward and
there's a lot of things that kind of go
along with that that you'll have to
watch and see
i mean are there are there challenges
are there hurdles along the way and how
do they as a couple navigate that
together yeah absolutely you know the
challenges are i think that we both have
different um different ideas of when we
want to have kids how many kids we want
to have and
it's frustrating for one of the
characters that won't say who
uh and then
there's also these other challenges of
you know i don't want to give anything
away but there's definitely a lot of
challenges that come along with the
planning and the
you know
going ahead with having kids
okay
so as as an objective fan of the show
remove yourself obviously from from any
bias what would you want to see kevin
and and sarah's family look like
um question
i think you know that they could start
kind of uh an adventure pack
family where we uh you know they kind of
go on and conquer the world one mountain
climb at a time
adventurous and that sort of thing and i
think that's kind of where kevin really
wants you know he jokes around in the
beginning of you know having a starting
lineup that many kids and i think that
that's exactly where he would want to go
and you know i just want to see them
succeed they're such nice people they're
great characters and they're both very
heroic so you know it's uh it'd be nice
to see them succeed and kind of get
everything they want but of course along
the way it'd be nice to see those
struggles so it's really worth it
do you think kevin will have five kids
like the family he came from
oh man i don't know hopefully
we'll see
okay cool
as as kevin and sarah begin this this
journey of family planning lacey i want
to pivot to you jess is also in the
throes of a very exciting time in her
life we left her as an engaged woman
i love a wedding i love a hallmark
wedding so i am hoping that you can
indulge us and tell us will there be a
wedding episode this season uh yes
this was
the
best season ever planning the wedding
with david
obviously you know the in-laws show up
and stir the pot a little bit so there's
a little drama
but um
filming this wedding was the most fun
i've ever had filming anything
tell me dance
harder
and laugh harder
that the wedding party then i get like i
i peed my spanx i'll tell you and i'm
not the only one
we will have so much fun yeah like i
can't discuss like obviously um it was
honestly it was like a real wedding it
was stressful it was so beautiful
it was amazing they did such a good job
they let me pick the dress
it was it was stunning it was everything
was emotional
yeah and it took two days so it was
exhausting
wow oh my gosh well now i'm flooded with
questions i mean first off
what does jess's dream wedding look like
is it big is it romantic is it more
outdoorsy and rustic what can you tell
us about the vibe
backyard intimate
rustic beautiful
fairytale you know
i have a question that day on set
were there were there like real tears i
mean i know that obviously lacy's
playing a character but seeing her in a
wedding dress did anybody get emotional
yes yes thank you i think you cried
we got emotional too because at the very
end there's this amazing drone shot that
go that starts
on on lacy and all of us dancing to
irish music and then it pulls out and
it's magnificent and you know the most
magnificent part of it where we got
tears was watching tree williams break
dance during the day
do you remember that now what kind of
tears they were
he did
they were
shame tears of shame my family
andrew you've had a huge smile glued on
your face ever since i brought up the
word wedding i mean what are some of
these memories that are coming back to
you that you can tease for fans about
that big episode
well uh you know for the wedding it was
a beautiful wedding it was absolutely
gorgeous it was on sort of the point and
just with the house in the background it
was gorgeous um but for the dancing part
i was dancing with gran
and uh so we would do about six seven
takes so by the end you know
diane actually wasn't there for that
portion of the dancing so they had
somebody else doing it uh a stand-in of
sorts and uh she had a an iwatch or an
apple watch on and after every time she
would check her heartbeat and that be up
at like 140 beats per minute
we almost we almost killed the dear
woman but she uh she gave it to me
andrew not we
you
yeah
you better check your heart palpitations
yeah we all do
yeah no it was a lot of fun yeah okay so
i'm hearing about break dancing i'm
hearing about a lot of fun but you know
what i love about a wedding is like a
real tearful moment i mean are there
emotional moments are there speeches or
or lacy is there a conversation maybe
that jess has with her her sisters or
something something that you can tease
that will really pull at our
heartstrings
i think the initial
like
take one of the wedding we walked down
the aisle i walked down the aisle with
treat and i wasn't expecting it but it
was like
like that was kind of a big moment for
for me for jess it was like i'm i'm
getting married and this is my dad and
this is happening and it was so
emotional for me and and treat you i
think a little bit oh yeah
that's easy i'm a big crybaby i i went
easily
since i have a daughter who's 22 and not
you know i'm hoping one day i'll be
doing the same with her so it was quite
wonderful
good practice i love greetings so it was
so nice to have a moment with lacy we
didn't have much together this year
right
when i was in i got to watch on adr i
got to see that that moment and i swear
it almost made me well up a little bit
too even though i'm in sort of a
business mode and not really into the
show but it was just watching the tears
on lacey's face and and treat welling up
and stuff like that i was like oh man
this this is emotional it was really
powerful yeah and carlo too just you two
were so beautiful and
lacy how you how you managed to finesse
that dress so much because you had your
hand in it do you remember when you're
doing that in your
dancing you really look like the
princess bride i just have to say i
think i kept saying that but you really
did look like the princess bride
i didn't when i got home everything was
like early
thanks yeah thank you
okay let's see let's leave fans with
this if you have to tease the wedding
episode in three adjectives what would
you say
ah
good question
magical
emotional
and perfect
i cannot wait i know it's gonna be
another epic hallmark wedding moment
and uh and andrew i want to pivot over
to you i want to talk about the esquire
he's about to go on a a fun new career
journey i want to know what what lies
ahead with this new job and uh the
complications and excitement that come
with it
yeah uh uh conor gets a great new job
he's working at a new firm uh denzer
lewis and phelps
it's a tough one we're all in trouble
with that line a little bit
that's the one though denzel lewis and
phelps yeah he gets this great job and
uh he's given a lot of responsibility
which is really really good for connor
and he's just soaking it up um he's kind
of in the place that he wants to be and
he starts to move up the ladder quite
quickly uh quicker than i even think
that he thinks it's going to happen
but as he does that he starts to notice
some looks and some conversations
happening
sort of behind his back maybe he's not
sure if he's being paranoid or not um so
you know he's getting all these
responsibilities he's moving up the
ladder but things may not be what they
seem so there's a little bit of mystery
and a little bit of suspense there
is there one moment in season five that
you're really excited for fans to see
with connor there most definitely is it
has to do with his job at denzel lewis
and phelps i i can't definitely give the
information on that it's about
mid-season um but it is an absolutely
beautiful beautiful scene uh there's two
of us on here that are in that scene and
uh the way we play off each other and
sort of the the comedy that's laced into
the scene just through our characters
like a lot of times you know the jokes
and past seasons have been i'd say kind
of on the nose and they're right there
but a lot of the comedy comes from just
character and situational and in this
sort of big epic almost mid-season
finale there's comedy mixed with drama
mixed with a little bit of a sting it's
it's uh it's it was super awesome to
film and uh had a great time and let us
not forget your new love interest
barbara barbara you could literally do
this job i was just about to say
what can you tease in terms of romance i
know he's a hard-working career guy but
is there time to find love
well you know i don't think he
necessarily has time to find love but um
he doesn't have time for love to find
him and
there there is this new paralegal that
starts working in the office and as
connor is uh is working hard and you
know these sort of little looks and
conversations are happening uh yeah this
new paralegal comes in and her name's
margaret she's played by raylene harwood
and she's a fantastic actress a
fantastic person and right away there's
some witty banter between them and uh
and it seems like there might be a
little bit of a spark there and she also
has sort of the inside scoop on uh
denzel lewis and phelps and sort of
helps connor along in sort of
you know
fielding this new situation at this new
big firm with these these sharks as
they're called wow
all right well we better buckle up it
sounds like connor's in for a wild
season
and i know we kind of talked about the
three of the o'brien siblings of course
amelia and megan couldn't be with us
here today but we love them we miss them
dearly and hopefully we'll chat with
them at some point during the season
i am hoping as members of the o'brien
family that maybe you guys can tease a
little bit about first let's talk about
brie i mean she went to london is she
coming back are we gonna find her back
with with family at the start of season
five and where does her journey go
oh she comes back
and she
is
yeah she's a couple of
romances
did you say a couple romances oh yes
milo
tell us more than one
i can tell you no i can't see i don't
know what i can say
when she comes back she happens to find
herself
in a new
um exciting
potential relationship with someone that
is would be kind of from her past that
would be not so great for her but
maybe they would work out and then while
that's trying to get figured out someone
else comes in that's a bit more suited
towards her and she's gonna have to kind
of navigate that
suffice to just say that this season
there's a lot
a lot more romance for everybody and
some
new hallmark punks are coming to
chesapeake shores this year too i mean
we already have you guys there you know
you're amazing but uh i think
everybody's going to be really pleased
and the people that they have now cast
and brought in are not only fantastic
actors but they fit right in as family
they're good people too they belong on
hallmark so
i and we we will get to the newcomers
but you're speaking my language here
when you you tease things like a
possible love triangle romances from the
past sort of bubbling up you know
with that you know with with brie as she
explores what's moving forward i i can't
help but bring up abby um you left us
with with the season four cliffhanger of
all cliffhangers uh we got that epic
traby kiss
and now we know moving forward right
jesse metcalf is not going to be part of
the show but
can you can you kind of you know set the
record straight are we going to see him
in season five and where does traby end
off
travie turns it turns out to be a trexit
yeah
jessie opted to uh to go another way and
so we had as i say
sutton and hallmark i think they
brilliantly pivoted quickly so jessie's
in the first two episodes okay and and
then um they they brought in just
just did an amazing pivot and brought in
a storyline and character that is so
different and yet so charming and you're
gonna root for him you're gonna root for
abby and just out and they start out as
tweet was saying as an old 30s movie
plot like the old kate hepburn and
spencer tracy like at each other like
this and then you know sometimes when
you're mad at somebody and angry that
you and maybe it's just the sparks
happening and you're gonna say no that's
that's not happening is it so i think
they'll be able to the fans will love
the journey that happens
okay and i i do want to talk about
robert buckley he's a fantastic actor
i'm so excited about him coming on the
show this season
lacey you're you're um abby's on-screen
sister i'm just curious you know for
fans who are wondering where is abby's
heart at right now what can you tell us
about that
the whole season it's abby claims her
heart is closed
and it's like no it's not what about
this guy what about this what about this
so um
jess will always get the inside scoop
just knows everything yeah
yeah gatekeeper of course
yeah
and
i really do think that you know robert
coming onto the show uh and his
character uh it brought sort of a
lightness and you know uh uh just a
breath of fresh air uh it like
they were able to sort of uh thief and
mark and and brian everybody was writing
the episodes you know they were able to
sort of add this different element that
the audience hasn't seen in past seasons
uh you know like a comedic element but
not trying to be funny i mean when i
would read the scripts i know all of us
you know we were all saying as soon as
we got searched we couldn't wait to read
them and i would laugh out loud like
genuinely gut laugh at the different
characters have been brought in and the
different relationships and that was a
brand new thing so not only does this
season have the drama and the romance
and um you know everything that the past
season's had but it has now this fun
bubbly energy that also includes drama
and romance so it just can become a much
more layered show and a much more
balanced show i think and i think also
if i may jump in there just the
relationship between um
abby
and uh
and rob's character is so much different
than the relationship with trace and
trace has been you know it's like a long
time that they were together and that
they knew each other and it was very
serious and how it was almost tumultuous
more than
anything
and
um with rob now
it's almost like a kid-like
refreshing
love and playful and it's really nice i
don't think that the audience has seen
that side of her and i think that
writers and rob really brought out that
um
and megan of course she's absolutely
talented but it just she's showing that
side a bit more and i think that it's uh
you know
not having jesse of course he's gonna be
missed but it's also extraordinarily
nice to have
someone come in with such a new flavor
and it's not a replacement it's just a
different storyline and i think that the
fans are really going to enjoy that so
there's not going to be any and and i
think if the fans watch abby
um abby giggle with evan um you i have
never i don't know about you guys but
i've never personally seen meg and ori
just light up and laugh and giggle so
much she's got the the giggle of all
time doesn't she he doesn't expect that
she looks like she'd be this
you know like having your giveaway or
something she's goofy and yeah every
character now is a has a greater depth
this season and and just i think that
the the writers dug into who we are and
watched who we are more as
as people as individual people and
they've added that layer to our
characters too so i think the fans are
going to discover brand new
depths to all of us into the show and to
the family than they've ever seen before
in season five can i can i just add one
thing that uh what's really wonderful
what's been great this year is that abby
uh joins mick in the business
oh yes
and that was really wonderful because it
gave megan and i a chance to uh
to have some really great stuff together
and to become partners and uh her value
to the to the family company is
extraordinary and and so that's been a
wonderful addition to make them
the company together rather than just
mixed company well it sounds like you
guys are delivering the most delicious
and rich season
possibly yet before we wrap up before we
wrap up this conversation i want to play
a quick rapid-fire game i'm hoping that
each of you can pinpoint the one
must-see moment in season five of
chesapeake shores that you are so
excited for fans to see tree let's start
with you you look like you're thinking
hard
i hate to say this but it has to be with
gregory harrison when we go camping
together as brothers
it's it's not pretty but it's very funny
i have to say there's a couple scenes in
the camping thing that i'm very proud of
we had a lot of fun
okay that sounds wild i'm ready for it
andrew
uh a big a big moment in the season that
i'm willing or i'm excited to see is
actually the very last scene of the
season uh there's um
there some stuff goes down this season
and uh you know by the very end it's
kind of a lot of stuff comes to a head
so i'm excited to see exactly where the
where the season ends off
okay so the final scene of season five
yeah i can't see anything more so much
happens only to get there but we got
whiplash doing it and i'm sure the fans
will too
andrew gets to act up a storm that's all
i'm going to say
right the hair is always on point
barbara what's your must-see moment in
season five um i
i personally loved filming a scene with
sarah um jessica sipos
um uh it's like i had another daughter
and i think it's a universal theme that
so many of us have gone through i cannot
tell you what it is but i think it
happens in towards the end of the season
but um oh my gosh what a fine actress
she is and
i i
it's one of my favorite scenes ever just
the two of us you know
just talking about women's stuff and
family and
and how when you go through something
it teaches you how to find your own
strength ultimately
and i know barbara can't say much more
about that but that scene was was talked
about like i mean we heard the next day
wow this scene is
powerful powerful stuff but that
happened multiple times this season you
know but that was one of them it was
like the next day it was like whoa whoa
whoa like everybody
you know either we can't say was either
laughing hysterically or crying
hysterically it was one of the two of
those
everyone is hysterical
[Laughter]
hysterical i thought there was a there
was a day out throughout the season
where we all said
one of us really brought it yesterday
and the word gets out really quickly and
it was really wonderful the support we
had for one another and every every one
of us had one of those moments given to
us everybody took them and ran with them
yeah yeah you're all powerhouses truly
brendan i want to know your season five
must-see moment
uh for me the musty moment i want is uh
i have a whole storyline with uh captain
of the firehouse
can get off again and urge to hang it
start and um
there's one scene when i go to his house
and i kind of discover what's going on
with him and i'm really excited to see
that that's a must-see and i think that
there's a lot of beauty and a lot of
silence and a lot of what's going on in
that and i think that the fans are
really gonna like that too yeah brendan
acted up a storm in that one too
i got to be in a bike race against
andrew and guess who won
team megan yes
i won't put it out there i want to say
what i just want to say that we all
could be accused on occasion of acting
up a storm
for better or worse yes
there were quite a few treat scenes that
were brought up the next day as well
that were like whoa
everybody had them yeah yeah they were
saying oh my god he was so over the top
it really feels like such an ensemble
like why did it take us five seasons to
truly gel as a family in an ensemble i
for so many reasons that i'm just so
proud of you to be on screen and a part
of the series with each one of you you
just you're my heart
i jailed with you guys in season one
what are you talking about
wait
and lacey we we've got to know your
favorite must-see moment season five
andrew you stole mine but it's actually
yours i want to see the final scene it's
like the biggest cliffhanger we've ever
had on the show so
i've heard all about it i read it but i
want to see i wait for that
and andrew does stunts
if acting doesn't work out you can
always do stunts babe no more
who knows if i do who knows if i don't
we'll see no you don't know
cliffhanger stunts if you had to
describe the finale in in a couple words
what would you say
it's epic it's absolutely epic like from
the start of the episode to the last
scene
whiplash my goodness okay buffo it's
buffo
we're doing throwback 30 stuff i'm
putting those words back in the show
yeah
keep them alive and well and listen
before i let you guys go i want to play
a really fun
rapid fire game i affectionately call
chesapeake shorelatives i'm gonna
i'm gonna throw out a title something
that you'd see you know maybe in in a
yearbook and you tell me who from the
cast in real life would be most likely
to do these things okay
who would be most likely in real life to
write their own screenplay or book
street williams
treat
yeah
i think that's probably true i just did
a play that i wrote so
i love i love it what can you tell us a
little bit
i wrote a one-man show about
ulysses grant
um and i did it the last two and three
nights ago in massachusetts and it went
very well so it looks like
do you have a link we could watch yeah
no no it was on stage
no video tape no iphone
who would be most likely to start their
own band
andrew andrew
sure yeah
he's already got the crystal things and
the singing balls
yeah if it's a
band made of just gongs and crystal
balls and uh and sometimes then i got it
covered yeah perfect
uh who would most likely be sorry who
would be most likely to start a side
hustle by opening up their own bed and
breakfast
that'd be brandon
so i'm doing it
you are
yeah that place is up and running
wow
brendan got his place up and running and
literally the moment that he did the the
ding ding ding dings on his phone just
would not stop and walked in like i mean
brendan like in no time and then he'd
lose one and go oh no i lost ding and be
again taken it was wild
how's it going brendan
it's great it's going great
yeah it's slowly blowing it's great
to peanut bridge columbia you can't go
wrong one of the prettiest places in uh
canada and brandon you have something to
fall back on if this doesn't work out
well thanks for putting that out in the
universe always nice
brendan i am curious was your work on
chesapeake shores at all influenced by
your decision
no
what jess didn't inspire you oh you sure
yeah well yes but lacey has inspired me
to be a better actor so i think i'll
just stick with that
good answer
who's likely to become the next great
entrepreneur and start a business and
just kind of flourish
andrew
okay
busiest person he can't sit still
leave as many businesses as it is yeah
can you tell us a few andrew yeah well i
have um obviously my acting my voice
acting uh but i have a um a meditation
business called zenden meditation where
we do in in-person classes and virtual
classes through our app and our website
uh and then i've just sort of uh taken a
big dive into producing uh we have a
call at 3 30 today to sort of ink
a big movie with the big movie star
who's in it uh and so we've been sort of
going down that venture as well so keep
myself nice and busy yeah in between
seasons do you sleep
i do but i have two new dogs and my
girlfriend so i sleep on just a little
sliver of the bed but yes
and andrew as you continue into your
production foray how likely are you to
hire your esteemed chesapeake shores
co-stars i am very very likely um some
of the projects are hallmark some of
them are for other networks and are a
little bit more gritty so uh i expect to
go around to all the people i mean we
all love each other after this five
years you know we've gelled so much that
the opportunity to work with like these
people is top-notch so they would be the
first people that i would go to i like
that answer and here's my last one who's
most likely to buy a boat and live
happily on the open seas
definitely me
maybe treat but me tell me
we'll go
yeah together there you go brandon and i
both grew up on the waters so we both
water babies i think we'd go together
we'll get about best friends on a boat
at each other
i love it
i'm actually headed to defino this
weekend and i'm staying on a 42-inch
boat just on the way outside of
brennan's place so hopefully i'm going
to see him you are
yeah are they getting many drones
if there are i'll keep my eye on them as
you mentioned
that's right
there's a shot from season three where a
drone is going over our boat and tree
caught me literally doing this towards
the drone trying to suck up camera time
and i have not been able to live it down
since
yeah your hair
[Laughter]
i have a feeling the hair is always
perfect it is yeah yeah that's what i
both treat the same way i mean
you too you watch my mother like son
they keep praying me and combing me like
i want it to fall around but they keep
coming over and
pushing it back and all that so i just i
stopped fighting it
yeah andrew this year has told me that
his hairline is is getting lower and
lower and mine is getting higher
and higher
that's a brotherly thing to say
his hair is so good that as soon as we
wrapped i had to cut mine off
and my eyebrows are about to connect
with my hairline
yeah
listen i have to tell you there's
obviously a lot of great hair on
chesapeake shores but i have to tell you
in the short amount of time that i've
spent with you fine folks today there's
a lot of love also between this cast
it's so obvious that you guys are are
not just a family on chesapeake shores
but very much off and i encourage all of
the chessies that are watching right now
to become part of this family you have
to tune in this sunday august 15th 8pm
hallmark channel people are bringing
their a-game and i cannot wait to see
what happens in season five thank you
all so much for your time can we can we
also ask peter to have people um live
tweet with us during the show and just
and uh we every single episode we all
jump on and it's so much fun for us to
watch and live tweet with all of you
guys and we wouldn't be here without
their fans we're so grateful
hashtag chessy's all day long thank you
guys again thank you thank you
[Music]
you